depuis dix ans on a eu une augmentation
de notre activité
d'environ 20%
au niveau des effectifs médicaux en mai
à 5 équivalents temps plein pour une
cible entre 16 et 18 pour fonctionner
correctement et on met un petit moment
de trois équivalents temps plein en
avoir le droit d'exercer la nuit
il ya dix ans n'était pas beaucoup plus
en fait j'ai regardé j'étais étonné on
était 6,5 et en fait on avait un recours
à l'intérim qui était plus facile
actuellement le recours à l'intérim est
difficile parce qu'on a une perte
d'attractivité dans notre établissement
qui est lié au fait qu'on a une grande
pénibilité de travail ou à prix
équivalent les intérimaires préfère
aller travailler dans des structures
plus petites où la charge de travail est
moins importante donc on a recours à
l'intérim qui est quasi inexistant on a
un temps additionnel qui est colossal on
est à 400 500 heures par an
on a un manque d'effectif paramédicaux
sur l'établissement il manque 30 cette
infirmière sur notre hôpital on a perdu
60 lits
en 18 mois on est passés 340 à 281 après
concernant la prise en charge des
patients
je crois que le mot indigne et le plus
simple et le plus parlant pour tout le
monde on peut attendre plusieurs heures
avant d'être pris en charge cette
semaine j'ai une dame de 95 ans qui
restait trente six heures dans le
couloir des urgences
on souhaite ça à aucun sauf aucun membre
de sa famille c'est juste intolérables
chaque nuit j'ai plusieurs personnes qui
dans dans le couloir des urgences
avant la crise qu'ovide ont affiché sur
les murs le nombre de personnes qui
dormaient dans les couloirs pour des
raisons sanitaires on a arrêté de mettre
des feuilles sur les murs mais les
personnes sont toujours là on a des
patients qui doivent uriner derrière un
petit paravent des fois on n'a pas assez
de brancards donc on met les gens sur
des fauteuils des fois on n'a pas assez
de couvertures donc ils ont froid en
fait on n'a pas assez de place il ya une
mise en danger des patients il ya des
défauts de surveillance n'a pas assez de
place notre hôpital est sous dimensionné
par rapport à notre activité
voilà je vous ai dressé un tableau un
petit peu rapide de la situation de mon
quotidien aux urgences de ce que de ce
que je viens tous les jours mais
comprend les urgences c'est aussi
comprendre la main et comprend laval
comme vous l'avez très bien expliqués en
fait les urgences il ya un effet domino
quand ça va pas et en fait les dominos
bretons toujours sur les urgences quand
la médecine générale est débordé ou
quand la médecine générale n'est plus
disponible aller aux urgences pour les
spécialités de ville pour les
spécialités d'hôpital aller aux urgences
le centre de soins non programmés fermée
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année aller
aux urgences mais moi je suis pas sûr
que les urgences elle soit ouverte en
fait pour les fins d'année aura
peut-être des nuits fermé est on en
train de se battre pour papier de jours
non plus qu'il soit fermé je vous
rappelle qu'on est quand même hôpital
support du département puis tel support
de j'ai acheté
il ya quelques années comme l'a très
bien dit louis soûlât en fait on oriente
et en triant et les soins urgents et
maintenant en fait on prend en charge
tout cet effet domino qui nous retombe
dessus parce qu'en fait la lumière est
allumée et on est là tout le temps parce
qu'on est les urgences en fait est que
quand on sait plus on est à la fois et
le premier recours les gens est le
dernier recours quand on sait plus quoi
faire quand on sait plus où aller on dit
aller aux urgences moi je vis dans un
département qu'il 5e m désert médical de
france 6,3 médecin pour dix mille
habitants il ya 10 % des plus de 16 ans
qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant donc
dire aux gens à aller voir votre médecin
traitant c'est en fait une façon très
polie de leur dire débrouillez vous
c'est pas rentable
ça c'est pour laval
donc l'ouverture de lits mais comment
faire quand ya pas de paramédicaux il ya
quelques années ont fermé des lits moi
j'ai une direction une ars qui ne
demandent que ça d'offrir des lits mais
ya pas de paramédicaux et pourquoi il
n'a pas parce qu'ils sont sont dégoûtés
par ce qu'un soignante n'est pas un
technicien
il faut revoir les ratios des ratios
soignants patients un soigneux doigt un
soignant doit être en forme et en bonne
santé pour prendre en charge un patient
qui par définition lui est en détresse
est actuellement nos soignants ils sont
usés et paramédicaux comme les médecins
pourquoi ils sont usés pour plein de
choses parce qu'il ya une charge de
travail des conditions de travail une
qualité de travail tout tout les
difficiles et puis il ya aussi des
petites choses qui paraissent
insignifiantes quand tout va bien et
qu'on aime son métier et puis quand tout
va mal on regarde aussi dans le détail
ce qui va pas laisser les statuts on a
déjà parlé des ambulances il leur parle
ils sont pas reconnus comme des
soignants voilà et donc quand on a tous
qui fonctionne bien s'intéressent pas
forcément à tous et on se bat pas pour
tous les combats ou là là on cherche en
fait à trouver ce qui va bien ce qui
nous motive ce qui nous donne envie de
nous lever le matin ce qui fait qu'on a
ou pas la boule au vent pour aller au
travail il ya le ségur avec l'oubli du
médico social voilà le soin ne doit pas
chercher en premier la rentabilité
le premier médicament je le dis toujours
c'est l'humain et donc il faut remettre
de l'humain dans le soin quand vous
arrivez aux urgences vous avez envie
qu'on vous accueille avec douceur et
gentillesse et qu'on prenne en compte
votre problème est qu'on soit
humainement disponibles pourra recevoir
votre détresse et actuellement on n'est
plus capable de le faire lundi j'étais
de garde j'ai fait plus de 25 heures de
garde parce que l'on vit pas sonné et
quinze minutes avant la fin de ma garde
donc je suis parti en interne je
rentrais chez moi je me suis reposé je
me suis lavé j'ai mangé et puis après
qu'est ce que j'ai fait je suis chef de
service des urgences de laval alors j'ai
fait mon travail de chef de service j'ai
fait une réunion avec mon équipe pour
préparer la certification et puis après
je suis allé à la cme j'ai fait des
réunions et en fait je n'ai pas dormi
minutes sur mon repos de garde et c'est
ça aussi que les gens n'ont pas
on arrive pas à comprendre c'est que à
un moment donné on n'est plus comme
autrefois où on avait des temps of sur
les gars maintenant le flou et constants
il diminue mais il est constant il est
la porte est ouverte et le flux est
constant les patients arrivent tout
temps voilà donc c'est ça qui est
difficile c'est pour ça qu'on a du mal à
enchaîner oui il ya des années on dit
oui non et hedegaard 48 heures 72 heures
mais là enfin je mets au défi n'importe
qui il travaillait 48 72 c'est juste
impossible
à la fin à la fin de cette année je je
je souhaite poser des congés comme comme
toujours depuis que je travaille donc je
fais aussi médecin généraliste jeunes et
diplômés de la camy en 2019 depuis que
je travaille je n'ai jamais eu des
conduits entier j'ai décalé mais plongé
de deux jours au lieu d'être en congé
vendredi soir je suis en congé dimanche
et je reviendrai mercredi soir au mieux
mes congés pour faire une garde parce
que sinon les urgences ferme
vous rendez compte de cette pression
qu'on a comporte je suis une maman de
quatre enfants et je vais leur dire en
plein milieu des vacances
dormez bien même si chez rim maman par
travail voilà une fois ils m'ont dit
mais il n'est pas au courant pré fille
qu'on est dimanche tout est en vacances
je fais 10,6 mais il ya des choses qui
sont plus importantes ici et par
l'enfant ça fait ça fait mal donc ce
témoignage que je vous offre avec tout
mon coeur et ma sincérité c'est aussi
des témoignages que j'ai reçus d'autres
chefs de services d'établissement qui
correspondent
voilà deux villes moyennes et on partage
il y as pour moi des solutions il ya des
solutions qui existent
je suis pas
du genre à regarder ce qui ne va pas
j'aime regarder aussi ce qui va bien on
a beaucoup d'énergie on fait un métier
de passion et on est toujours force de
proposition dans les réunions on a
beaucoup d'idées mais voilà on a des
contraintes des lourdeurs
administratives des fois qu'il nous
empêche d'avancer et d'avancer vite moi
je suis urgentistes attendre une heure
c'est déjà beaucoup quand on dit on
verra ça dans trois semaines ou dans un
mois ça me parlait
invraisemblable la dé la notion de temps
entre un urgentiste et un administratif
c'est là on n'est pas dans le même monde
donc nous on a besoin d'avancer on a des
idées mais on veut que ça va ensuite on
a des contraintes administratives
qui nous bloque je pense et j'assume ce
que je vais dire c'est qu'il faudrait
revoir la régulation d'installation
aussi parce que c'est peut-être pas
drôle d'exercer dans un désert médical
mais c'est pas drôle dit vivre quand on
n'a pas de médecin traitant
il faut revoir aussi les projets
architecturaux pour à dimensionner
correctement pour accueillir les
patients et puis est attractif voilà
c'est important d'avoir un cadre certes
beau mais aussi adapter à la capacité
qu'on nous demande d'avoir en terme de
passage de patients et puis
valoriser nos soignants
c'est à dire que on dans le seigneur on
parle d'une infirmière de fin de
carrière mais ça n'existe plus les
infirmières de fin de carrière elle
s'arrête avant donc il faut stage irisé
précocément les soignants il faut
valoriser dès le début des carrières il
faut favoriser tout ce qui est innovant
comme les infirmiers en pratique avancée
les délégations de tâches le sas pour
moi aussi c'est une solution et le lien
en ville hôpital nous dans notre
établissement on avait on à la cellule
d'ordonnancement impro spitalier et puis
on a une cellule aussi ville hôpital
mais la personne qui
devait prendre ce poste a été écoeurée
par les conditions de travail la
lourdeur la difficulté elle est partie
donc on a en fait
plein d'idées plein de projets mais il
ya plus il ya plus personne en fait pour
les mener avec
moi je fais ce métier par passion
j'estime que je fais le plus beau métier
du monde et je crois à l'hôpital public
et c'est pour ça que je me bats je
m'accroche et j'ai envie qu'on arrive
tous ensemble à amener des solutions
parce que la trop longtemps on a
considéré que la santé c'était la sphère
des soignants mais la santé c'est la
firme de tous les citoyens et
il faut vraiment s'intéresser en
profondeur et avec tous les acteurs et
tous les partenaires à la médecine
demain et
redonner la passion les lettres de
noblesse à la santé merci
[Musique]